J'allais en Inde pour obtenir mon master
Avec la guerre
La situation qui s'est produite m'a obligé à revenir
L'état du nord pour les dates de récolte avec
[musique]
Les prix des dattes sont bas, sans parler d'autres choses
En raison de l’absence de marché, notamment pour les fonds des commerçants
Ceux qui ont peur et veulent acheter chez nous parce que c'est vrai
Le premier, le dernier et le plus proche marché était celui de Khartoum.
Mais il y a des tentatives, si Dieu le veut, pour ouvrir les marchés
Malgré l'augmentation du coût
[musique]
J'ai besoin que l'État me donne des soins et de l'attention
Fournit aux agriculteurs des conseils agricoles
Méthode scientifique de culture et de récolte
Et un stockage de manière scientifique qui garantit la qualité
Production
[musique]